buongiorno buongiorno a tutti
perdonerete un po di emozione perché
questo è il posto più bello dove vi sia
mai capitato di parlare ai pubblico
quindi è una cosa che intimidisce
quindi mi perdonerete
ed è forse in posti come questi
straordinari come questi che noi
sentiamo
come norma umana sul pianeta ormai sia
diventata norma di uno scarpone chiodato
quanto ci indigniamo quando vediamo
quelle foto quei video
delle plastiche in mare negli oceani
quando vediamo i delfini e tartarughe
oppresse microplastiche dalle plastiche
soffocate il respiro del mondo e
soffocato dall'inquinamento della
plastica ed è giusto che noi ci
indigniamo ed è giusto che noi ci
arrabbiamo per cui questo ci aiuta ad
assumere dei comportamenti individuali
sani
però
oltre all'indignazione dovremmo avere un
po più di attenzione nei confronti delle
soluzioni al problema ambientale delle
soluzioni al problema dell'emergenza
climatica e su questo secondo me c'è
minore attenzione anzi in particolare
c'è scarsissima attenzione
sulle soluzioni ambientali che vengono
realizzate brevettate sperimentate
esportate da noi qui in italia
a proposito delle plastiche lo sapete
che pochi sanno che la soluzione più
radicale al problema dell'inquinamento
da plastica al netto naturalmente del
riciclo della plastica ma la soluzione
più radicale
l'abbiamo brevettata noi la bioplastica
e cioè la plastica compostabile
biodegradabile che si fa con il rifiuto
organico
sia mater bi se voi guardate lo shopper
del supermercato lo guardate in fondo
piccolo piccolo piccolo c'è scritto
mater bi
e anche quando è prodotto in austria è
fatto su licenza di un'azienda di novara
a novara un team di chimici con a capo
una signora chimica la signora catia
bastioli hanno inventato alcuni anni fa
il mater bi ed è un primato mondiale
abbiamo inventato noi
bene c'è un reticolo di
imprese di centri di ricerca di
cercatori di consorzi di associazioni di
università nel nostro paese che ci
consentono di dire che noi sul cammino
verso un nuovo modello di sviluppo eco
sostenibile noi italiani ci stiamo e ci
stiamo molto bene
noi siamo la prima economia circolare
dell'unione europea per il terzo anno di
seguito il nostro indice di economia
circolare superiore a quello della
germania della francia della spagna la
nostra media di riciclo dei rifiuti e il
doppio della media europea
quindi facciamo meglio dei tedeschi dei
francesi degli spagnoli
siamo primi in fotovoltaico e abbiamo
tutta una serie di altri primati di
recente all'eco forum ma abbiamo
presentato un sondaggio in cui abbiamo
scoperto che il 13 per cento degli
italiani sa che cosa in italia si fa per
l'ambiente ma quello che è più grave che
abbiamo scoperto che se tu dici a dieci
italiani
che noi siamo più bravi dei tedeschi
nella gestione dei rifiuti
beh il 60 per cento degli italiani mi
risponderanno non è possibile non è
possibile che noi siamo più bravi dei
tedeschi
quindi dobbiamo averla questa
consapevolezza è vero che l'italia è
lunga
noi tendiamo a parlare delle nostre
contraddizioni dei nostri errori dei
nostri problemi delle nostre incapacità
delle nostre impotenze delle nostre
debolezze dei nostri difetti e nessuno
naturalmente vuole nascondere tutto
questo però
vogliamo riequilibrare un po la nostra
narrazione sul nostro paese vogliamo un
po sottolineare le nostre capacità le
nostre potenzialità
a pochi a non molti chilometri da qui
nel trevigiano
50 comuni del trevigiano
toccano il
record europeo assoluto di riciclo dei
rifiuti
è un'azienda pubblica sia contarina del
trevigiano
è un esempio mondiale mondiale di
gestione dei rifiuti e vengono da tutto
il mondo a studiare il funzionamento di
contarina e lì si sperimentano delle
tecnologie per esempio sul riciclo dei
pannolini che è una cosa importantissima
nessuno si rende conto di quanti
pannolini si consumano ogni giorno la
decina di milioni al giorno
e sono composti di materie nobili perché
appunto sono alla pelle quindi devono
essere materie nobili bene lì è stata
sperimentata una tecnologia unica al
mondo in cui si possono riciclare queste
sostanze economia circolare guardate che
queste cose sono presenti nella chimica
verde ve l'ho già detto la plastica
nella bioedilizia nella moda nella great
food è italiana l'azienda maggiore
produttrice di energie rinnovabili al
mondo ed è un'azienda pubblica
qui non faccio il nome ma ma giro che
pensiate subito qual è
quindi da questo punto di vista noi
possiamo
raccontarci delle cose positive
o due minuti vi voglio raccontare la
storia di due ragazze catanesi che
ragionando sul loro futuro a un certo
punto hanno un'idea quella di utilizzare
il residuo della lavorazione delle
arance per farne dei tessuti sono brave
si fanno finanziare questo questo
progetto se lo fanno sperimentare al
politecnico di milano fondano una
startup adesso quella è un'azienda che
lavora per marchi globali che esporta in
tutto il mondo che assume che investe
e guardate e ha due sedi una catania e
una rovereto e guardate quanti
significati ci sono in questastoria due
giovani due ragazze due ragazze del sud
l'economia circolare con
l'agricoltura il residuo delle arance la
moda atipica nostra del made in italy il
mediterraneo la nostra cultura il nostro
sole quale altro paese può
riassumere in una singola storia tutti
questi significati positivi
io ho raccontato queste storie di
recente ci ho lavorato e forse avrei
potuto
pubblicare un libro che era il triplo di
quello che ho pubblicato dalle storie
che ho raccontato guardate che sono
tante allora raccontarcele non significa
cancellare i nostri errori ma significa
magari rimediare ai nostri errori e poi
migliora migliora il nostro umore
migliore il nostro umore nazionale
diminuisce un po quel certo masochismo
che che ci contraddistingue che non ci
fa bene io penso che dobbiamo rendere
giustizia al nostra la nostra capacità
di essere presenti sul terreno di un
nuovo modello di sviluppo che è l'unico
che dobbiamo
intraprendere perché il pianeta non
respira più
e ci obbliga a cambiare il nostro
modello di sviluppo per il futuro da
subito però noi italiani non siamo già
facendo quindi riconosciamo cielo perché
in fondo ce lo meritiamo e questa è una
cosa che è bene che ci raccontiamo
grazie della vostra attenzione sono otto
minuti esatti
[Applauso]